j'ai pour vous une énorme surprise c'est
quoi c'est quoi un invité alors là non
un avis mais vu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de ramener le quart sont des cubes de
francine on arrêtera cocorico tu vois il
c'est bon on est happé et mokhtar il est
passé la prime quand il remet la
combinaison complète de l'équipe de
france ah ouais quoi ils rentrent dedans
lui il a plu short choix ah ouais bon ça
va lui un amour
franchement tu es un amour celui d'hier
[Applaudissements]
c'est peut-être ça a changé depuis la
cohésion tout le monde ne te reconnais
maintenant oui depuis la coupe du monde
c'est vrai qu'un grand changement c'est
le regarder chez des gens qui ont changé
et par fonds sont bons je parle pour moi
personnellement je me sens mal à l'aise
ah oui c est dur de redescendre alors
qu'on a une saison à jouer maintenant
c'est c'est pas facile mais bon j'ai pas
m'en plaindre non plus mais adil qui va
sauver la vie cet été je suis allée chez
le coiffeur et sur la tête de ma mère
j'avais chaud il fit un pas et fama ici
tout raser ici pas rasé et chez rendez
vous avec lui et je vois dans sa tête on
voit et il veut pas me le dire tout de
suite parce qu'il m'aime bien donc il
fait cammas est joué pendant 20 minutes
ils ne parlent pas et après ça un petit
peu à 3 mètres comme ça il me regarde de
loin comme ça et là il m'a dit frérot
c'est une catastrophe tape cul tu vas
passer en été d'enfer et ima ima il a
fait venir un mec exprès à 2 200 km non
250 kilomètres pour me rattraper le
délire saint gobain référé merci
d'ailleurs le parquet de marseille
marseille va sauver la vie
le lendemain on s'est revus mais tu
avais la casquette on aurait dit ta tête
nordine l'une avait des cratères et le
soir et le soir ils m'envoient des
whatsapp secondes mais je te
conseillerais de te regarder à trois
mètres de distance a dit le mon chéri tu
es champion du monde mais je pense que
tu voudras est aussi champion du monde
de boîtiers non mon frérot est ce que tu
peux faire ça valait ce que tu peux te
faire 1 1
un petit plaisir déjà tu fais un type à
terre avec benjamin kasami a dénoncé et
après montargis où c'est parti on y va à
adil rami on se bat pas l'asm champions
est ce qu'ils se blessent pas pendant
qu'on joue avec les mains tu peux te
donner
dis moi tu lui as dit attention vous
allez aller à 2,3
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en cas de sérieux effets commune qui
nous lie je fais combat alors attention
qu mccomas kg 135 kg sa tête
[Rires]
alors ils se connaissent
attention attention les gars bien sûr
les gars ça fait longtemps qu a dit long
rêve il m'en a parlé tout l'état il veut
battre mot car on va faire si vous nous
rejoignez à dire à nos champions du
monde contre mokhtar est champion
tunisie chez lui les radiations de
natation est bon attention ouah 2 à 1
attention je lui qui casse en pro d2
bon
j'aime ça s'est mal passé
[Applaudissements]
bon voilà